so wait wait you so max you're gonna
judge um an upcoming drag show right is
that true yes thank you have you always
want to do this I want to see I want to
say I've wanted to well specifically
this one it's called best in drag La
it's okay Sports uh the alliance for
housing and healing which uh supports
homeless people in Los Angeles uh finds
housing for them specifically those who
are uh
uh who have HIV and AIDS wow they do
this every year it's this massive drag
show I've asked every year if I could be
uh one of the judges to no avail
and I finally got in
so wait what are so wait what do you
love most about a drag show what's
what's going to win you over well I
appreciate the commitment
I mean they are the point of drowning
but he really does the commitment to the
outfits the names the back story
everything that's it's just it's it's
spectacular it's all I want they're more
committed than I am as a father
that is not true we're taking that out
we're taking that out that is not true
we'll leave it in only because it's not
true
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]